[Music]
on this Monday night tough questions for
London Ontario Police the push for
answers about why it took so long to lay
charges in the hockey Canada sex assault
case and I'm apologizing to the victim
as Sheldon Kennedy sees progress in how
allegations are handled and we expect
the truth and
transparency cancer diagnosis King
Charles starts treatment and withdraws
from public duties A Tale of Two storms
on two coasts The Big Dig in Atlantic
Canada the front door is blocked in the
back There's 7 ft of snow and the super
soer in
California global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us the case of the five former
junior hockey players charged with
sexual assault is moving ahead and
police in London Ontario where the
alleged assault took place in 2018 are
now answering questions for the first
time since charges were laid the players
four of them now with the NHL did not
appear in court today their lawyers
represented them via video link they all
intend to plead not guilty and the chief
of the London Police Force apologized to
the victim today saying he is not happy
charges have taken so long I'm
apologizing to the victim and to her
family because it's taken this long this
should not take this long here is the
timeline police say the alleged assault
took place in June 28 in London in
February 2019 police closed their
investigation it was reopened in July
2022 charges were laid on January 31st
2024 that's almost 6 years after the
incident was first reported to police
the woman at the center of this is known
only as em and today the police referred
to her as the victim saying they
consulted her and she does not want to
be described as a complainant or a
Survivor Eric senson is outside the the
courthouse in London Ontario Tonight
Eric one thing that's still unclear is
exactly why London Police reopened the
case well Donna Police say that more
evidence came to light in 2022 though
they wouldn't say what it is but they
are admitting as you pointed out that
the investigation took too long and what
became clear today is that the entire
legal process is going to be a long one
and it's really just getting underway
London's Ontario well Donna Police say
that more evidence came to light in 22
though they wouldn't say what it is but
they are admitting as you pointed out
that the investigation took too long and
what became clear today is that the
entire legal process is going to be a
long one and it's really just getting
underway London's Ontario court of
justice Drew Global attention Monday
only the lawyers appeared in court by
video link for five professional hockey
players charged with sexual assault
including four nhlers they were told by
the crown to expect substantial evidence
in the case the players were only
recently charged even though a woman
told police she was assaulted in this
London hotel in 2018 after a hockey
Canada event celebrating the world
junior hockey team that the five accused
played for London Police dropped their
initial investigation in 2019 now in
front of an enormous media contingent
they were asked why the case was closed
and reopened 3 years later you know
again I can't speak to that police chief
Ty Trung said repeatedly he can't speak
about their own internal review while
the case is before the courts but he
implied there were shortcomings in an
investigation that for the sake of the
alleged victim took too long I want to
extend on behalf of the London Police
Service my sincerest apology to the
victim to her
family for the amount of
time that it has taken to reach this
point the chief acknowledged the London
Force has has work to do to reassure
victims of sexual assault strengthening
building Community Trust is a big
priority for us and we're going to work
towards building the trust and repair
repairing some relationships this law
professor was more blunt it seems that
there were systemic failures in how the
investigation was done which seemed to
be cursory and inadequate other critics
say institutions from the police to the
NHL reflect a culture in this country
that for too long has not held abusive
Behavior accountable it's been a culture
of silencing and enabling of this very
masculine culture that often is
dehumanizing to others particularly to
women however long the police
investigation has lasted expect the
court case to be every bit as long and
difficult if it goes to trial it's going
to be very tough for the victim it's
going to be very tough for the witnesses
and dealing with five defense lawyers
it's going to be a lengthy lengthy trial
and we'll see what the outcome is
lawyers for the five players say they
will plead not guilty so there is every
reason to believe that a trial will take
place in this case and that it will be a
long one the next court appearance for
the five accused will be April 30th just
as the first round of the playoffs are
underway Donna Eric senson in London
Ontario tonight thanks a little later
I'll speak with former NHL player and
co-founder of the respect group Sheldon
Kennedy on whether he thinks hockey
culture has changed the sexual assault
trial of the Canadian military's former
head of Human Resources heard testimony
today from the woman making the
allegations this case dates back to 1991
when the woman says now retired vice
admiral Hayden Edmonson raped her while
on board a Navy ship he was a high-
ranking officer she testified saying she
froze and kept quiet during the alleged
attack fearing for her life what would
have been the consequence of me yelling
me pushing me saying no me not following
orders she told the Ottawa Court
Edmonson has denied any wrongdoing and
pleaded not guilty to one count of
indecent acts and one count of sexual
assault there is more upheaval in the
royal family King Charles has been
diagnosed with cancer Buckingham Palace
says it was discovered while the King
was being treated for an enlarged
prostate but that it is not prostate
cancer he's already begun treatment and
has stopped his public duties Crystal
ganing on what more we
know shock and concern is the RO royal
family divulg the king's cancer
diagnosis I mean hopefully he does well
this Canadian family in disbelief over
the Revelation I know my parents are
pretty uh my mom especially is is pretty
uh shaken by the news she's always
followed the
monarchy his majesty started treatment
Monday the cancer was found as the King
was receiving treatment for an enlarged
prostate Buckingham Palace has not
identified what type of cancer the King
has oh
are of course with his majesty and his
family and with all wish to send him our
very best wishes from the British House
of Commons to the Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau also wished the
king well and a speedy recovery British
media Outlets report Prince Harry will
travel from the US to visit his father
King Charles according to the Pala
statement remains wholly positive about
his treatment the 75-year-old ascended
to to the throne in September 2022 and
in sharing the news hopes it may assist
public understanding for all of those
around the world who are affected by
cancer in the statement from Buckingham
Palace it says the king will continue
with State business and official
paperwork and looks forward to returning
to full public duty as soon as possible
Donna all right crystal ganing in London
thanks days after announcing an
exclusive deal with L law manual life is
now backtracking can Canadians will be
able to fill specialty drug
prescriptions at any pharmacy the
insurance giant reverse course after a
backlash from customers manual life had
told people about 260 medications would
only be covered at Shoppers Drug Mart
and other law blah owned pharmacies that
included drugs for rheumatoid arthritis
Crohn's disease and cancer manual life
says patients covered under the program
represent less than 1% of all those
insured through its
company d ous blizzard-like winter
conditions brought much of Nova Scotia
to a halt over the weekend A lot of
people are calling this snowed in 2024
since Friday as much as 150 cm of snow
has fallen on parts of that Province
there's so much so fast that windows and
doors were blocked these people had to
shovel their Windows to get out of their
homes the storm has left thousands in
the dark shut down schools triggered a
local state of emergency in Cape Breton
Heidi petach on the efforts to dig out
and clean up all right let's take a look
see what's going on out
here a wall of snow greeted Glenn Gould
when he opened his door in Sydney Mines
Sunday the snow just kept coming and
coming and coming and it was like two
three days of of non-stop snow the front
door is blocked the windows glaz Bay
resident Pam Leader's home is barely
visible in this photo as snow from her
roof slid off I don't know how many
people at this point can't get out of
their doors or Windows this time- lapse
shows just how the snow piled up
knocking out power to thousands
throughout the province and creating
dangerous conditions I even heard about
a vehicle that was abandoned left on the
road covered in snow and the plow hit it
so it was becoming a real Hazard so the
Cape Breton Regional municipality
declared a local state of emergency
Sunday and asked the Nova Scotia
government for extra plow power the
province is moving equipment from other
parts of the province uh to the areas
that are in most of need and Ottawa is
now putting up resources too the parks
Canada equipment that it all is actually
I was told not too far away already I'm
in Dartmouth right now where environment
Canada's weather summary States anywhere
from 33 to 52 cm of snowf creating
drifts like this so imagine then what
it's like in Sydney Cape Breton where a
volunteer weather Observer recorded 150
cm
I just hope that uh everybody out there
got the help that they needed and that
uh everybody is okay people throughout
the region are now focused on digging
out many schools will remain closed the
historic cleanup underway Heidi pic
Global News
Halifax parts of California are getting
drenched right now satellite imagery
shows a massive storm system stalled
over the southern part of that state
it's called an atmospheric River and it
is the second in 2 weeks about 38
million people are under flood alerts
tonight Jackson prco reports on how
Californians are
coping this is already a storm for the
history books dumping nearly 6 months
worth of rain on Los Angeles in just a
few days bringing the first ever
hurricane force wind warnings to parts
of the California coast there was very
high wind on the bridge in the Hollywood
Hills there's incredible damage from
mudslides as this powerful atmospheric
River delivers more moisture than the
ground can handle evacuation orders were
issued for areas most at risk of
flooding it's extremely traumatic uh to
leave your house and not know what
condition it's going to be when you get
back near San Jose the Water Rose so
fast people and their dogs had to be
rescued while down trees and power lines
have left hundreds of thousands in the
dark I think the tree and the weather
just didn't have a good mix
scientists say El Nino and the changing
climate have supercharged weather
systems this is very rare an unusual and
a strong signal of a very high risk of
significant flash flooding and with more
rain in the forecast officials warn of a
potentially life-threatening situation
for the next several days an unrelenting
Deluge California won't soon forget
Jackson prco Global News
Washington two days of morning are
underway in Chile after at least 122
people were killed by wildfires on that
country's Central Coast conditions were
safe enough for some residents to return
to some neighborhoods today to search
through the debris about 1,400 homes
have been damaged Rescue Services are
struggling to get to other areas and
more than 300 people are still believed
to be missing a plea for Aid coming up
what Canada is intending to destroy that
Ukraine would like in its
Arsenal
Ukraine's President Vladimir zalinski
has said an overhaul of that country's
military and civilian leadership is
needed to reboot the war effort against
Russia hinting a major shakeup of his
government is imminent and it could
include replacing Ukraine's top military
commander all this is happening at a
precarious time Ukraine relies on
Western allies to supply it with weapons
and ammunition and it has never had
enough the Netherlands says it is
preparing to send more americanmade F6
fighter jets US senators have unveiled a
$60 billion Aid package for Ukraine but
that's being stalled by Hardline
Republicans now as Jeff simple reports
Ukraine's top Military Intelligence
officer is urging Canada to donate
decommissioned rockets that are slated
for
disposal the Frozen front lines in
eastern
Ukraine nearly 2 years since Russia's
full-scale Invasion Ukraine is running
desperately short of weapons and ke is
is now hoping Canada can provide a
Lifeline we are grateful Canada has been
assisting but we need more says
leftenant general Killa budanov in an
exclusive interview Ukraine's spy Chief
told global news they've asked Ottawa
for a
donation securely stored inside a
warehouse at this military Depot near
Saskatoon are more than 880,000
Rockets known as Canadian rocket vehicle
or CRV 7s they were developed in
Winnipeg during the Cold War used to arm
Canadian and NATO war planes but our Air
Force no longer needs them the Rockets
were retired two decades ago and are now
slated to be destroyed Ukraine wants to
give these Cold War relics new purpose
it's thousands uh enemy tanks that can
be destroyed this Ukrainian Special
Forces member and weapons expert whose
identity were concealing says they've
developed ground launchers capable of
firing the CRV 7s he and his team have
offered to travel to Saskatchewan to
inspect the rockets and handle the
transport what the general situation in
Ukraine it's hard to find bullets in
shops Jeff we're asking for some
something that you don't
need something that you will never use
but several months since making the
request they're still waiting for an
answer the federal government has signed
a contract with a company to safely
dispose of the rockets and Canadian
officials also o cited safety concerns
in a statement the defense minister said
we are pursuing testing to ensure that
this equipment is operationally
effective and safe to transport to
Ukraine before any potential donation
several weapons experts told global news
that if stored properly the CRV 7s
should be functional Canada you're in
peace time you don't get to tell Ukraine
what isra isn't a good risk this
Canadian adviser to Ukraine's military
says if some of the Rockets no longer
work the ukrainians can still make use
of the
parts we need a lot of equipment the
general says in this case Canada can
save taxpayers money by transferring
this equipment to us we hope it will be
a
win-win each day Canada mols its
decision he says more ukrainians are
dying Jeff simple Global News
Toronto still ahead I speak with Sheldon
Kennedy who knows about abusive culture
within hockey and is working to change
it
and back to our top story now the sexual
assault charges against former junior
hockey players with me is Sheldon
Kennedy he is the co-founder of the
respect Group which provides Education
and Training to organizations and
individuals on how to eliminate bullying
abuse harassment and discrimination
Sheldon thanks for being with us yeah
thanks for having me Donna Sheldon I
know you were able to listen to some of
what the London Police Chief said today
he apologized to the victim for the
length of time it's taken to lay charges
almost 6 years the outcome we know of
course will now be decided in court but
what does the way that this case has
played out so far say to you about the
handling of sexual assault cases
generally these are very difficult cases
to uh not only investigate uh but to
also um you know bring a conviction to
and you know it's absolutely Paramount
that we uh you know come at this in a
coordinated manner because the impact on
the victim is real and we've learned so
much about the impact so you look at
this case that's playing out now going
on almost six years uh Donna I mean it
is going to have it take take its toll
on on not just the victim but the
victim's family and and I think all of
those involved well I know since 2004 I
believe it is you've dedicated been
dedicated to instilling a culture of
respect within hockey you've trained
thousands of people you're working with
the NHL and with Hockey Canada
Are We There Yet unless we acknowledge
accept and identify uh the the change
needed and prioritize it within the
organization uh doesn't matter what we
have going on within the organization
we're never going to be able to see the
shift or the change or the the the
growth that we all want to see because
let's face it I mean you know I I mean
I've got I've got young kids Don I've
got a I have a 5-year-old son and I got
a one and a half-year-old and I know you
know one of my we were sitting at supper
table the other night and and I was off
to do an interview and and my my
5-year-old asked me he says where you
going dad and I said I'm going to go do
an interview and he said on what and I
needed to and they caught me caught
caught me off guard and and I and it I
took the took a minute to explain that
so I feel that a lot of families and
parents are probably finding themselves
in that situation and I think it's a
time for us as parents and and and as
adults to understand to learn better and
to be able to try to have that
conversation for our kids because it's
it it provides a a uh you know a time to
do that you know that's so important I
have a 19-year-old son and we've had
conversations about this too it it is so
important that it sort of starts there
Sheldon a situ if a situation were to
emerge uh like this today with these
kind of allegations of abuse against
junior hockey players how confident are
you that things would be handled
differently I'm confident Don I think
that uh I think that there's been uh you
know uh Lessons Learned uh lessons
learned the hard way um but I am also
confident that uh um there's been an
understanding that uh um you know the
way we've always done or the way that
you know business was always done when
these cases would arise of sweeping them
on the carpet that make them go away uh
is absolutely uh not the way that they
have to be dealt with uh or that they
can be dealt with and I I feel confident
that uh um uh you know cases would not
be handled uh in that in that way again
here all right Sheldon Kennedy thank you
I appreciate your work and your Insight
tonight thanks thank you
Donna your Canada are these big horn
sheep near Hinton Alberta we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at global.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]